you ever try to read a traffic sign when
you're in Wales yeah opposite day my
boxers cinched everything up yeah yeah I
noticed that you were hilarious and
fatal attraction hi lad Bible
I'm Paul Rudd I'm here with Michael
Douglas let's answer your questions yeah
I thought it would be do it was your
last day of filming and I thought it
would be funny to try and recreate that
classic scene you were in if you were
sitting across from me and I tried to do
what Sharon Stone did in Basic Instinct
and so I didn't want to tell you and I
thought it would be funny during your
long monologue if I could somehow expose
myself and away and cross my legs in a
way and that but when I sat down in the
chair my boxers cinched everything up
yeah yeah I noticed that
yeah so I had to pull my shirt down to
try and reach under to get everything
out again but can I just say what a
professional you are you just kept going
and I watched the playback and there was
a moment where your eyes just flickered
down a couple a couple times kept going
until you finally stopped and asked if I
was just a pervert there might have been
in there might have been another word
right in the middle right before and
what are you a something pervert well
you're hilarious
it's look at it now I mean it's it's a
play is taking 70 years I am enjoying it
I'm taking my leave from you absolutely
not true you were hilarious and fatal
attraction is especially that part with
the bunny no well she's heard you know
anybody well she knows Welsh I mean it's
a it's a it's a tough language you ever
try to read a traffic sign when you're
in Wales yeah apples with me
decaying at a much more rapid rate on
the inside it's it's it's all that find
a difficult for them to ask that
question since Paul is older than I am
it is a lot to be said for the CGI work
you know let's just say more money went
into this than any of the ants sorry
with all due respect England yeah yeah
very well
births not bad
we were actually in Paris for the final
and that was insane yeah what was it I
mean I was that left I left whether I
was going on if I was going on that
night was a bit insane oh yeah that was
maybe a good move smart but it was it
was yeah I went out of the Champs
Elysees was I've never seen crowds quite
like that do you know any real ant
facts I don't know the last one that I
talked to didn't share this information
that that's the thing about Anne's
they're very secretive they don't they
don't divulge much anything it's that's
the way they've been around as long as
they have it my favorite aunt fact is
that his real name is Stuart Goddard